when you learn how to enjoy being
underestimated it gets real good setup
log morning it's a Tuesday twenty fourth
of July headed to go see some executives
at a fortune 500 company just on my
house on my grind just wanted to give a
huge shout out to everybody on YouTube
and Facebook for watching the blog means
the world to me
I appreciate the attention I appreciate
the community all the comments we're
reading or reading reading a big shout
out to everybody who timestamps and says
this is fire that's leading to us making
a lot of great content so just thank you
so much really just appreciate the
community thank you so much Instagram
story people you know one thing to say
you got one [ __ ] life do something
with it
so many of you living your life based on
somebody else's opinions so grazie stop
it there's not gonna be a single
convenience store in America in 20 years
like we're thinking about things in 20
and 40 year windows not in 5000 year
windows like I don't like social time at
the store really you'll find other
things to do you know like you like and
by the way
ready for this and this will make sense
you if you are a person that thinks
social time of the store is a thing
you'll be able to go to the store
something there's not gonna be stores
it's just that leases are gonna have to
change dynamics are gonna have change
experiences are gonna have to change
like [ __ ] supermarkets in big-box
retail they didn't exist in 1947 you
went on the Main Street like go meat
everything said about supermarkets and
big-box retail it's all the same [ __ ] we
hold the past on a pedestal and we
demonize the future I'm trying to get my
kids to have more screen time not less
I want the logical answer of why we
should limit our kids screen time not
that you didn't grow up that way no
logical what world do you think they're
gonna live in so my guy
I'm doing this because of you I have a
business I just started just bought
myself that cameras got a 20,000 I'm
here working because of you because you
told me to work a 40-hour job like [ __ ]
this my guy what's your name
they've David it's a real pleasure to
meet you man David I'm mr. Bernardo
don't my not that artist you see me so I
can't wait
such a pleasure to meet you how are you
good how are you partner
good to see you oh good I was at eighty
four thousand followers on Instagram 18
months ago after being on it for five
and a half years eighty four thousand I
don't think I'd be at three point six
million if I thought about how to get
from eighty four thousand to one hundred
thousand
correct and they'll get you know what's
funny they're smart in the end they're
not so smart in the beginning people
fall for you know sizzle a lot i
sandbagged myself because i'm so in the
long game like andy and like my team
like the biggest complaint this little
squad has is like when can we start
making the content more about you being
smart like that's just not even a part
of my narrative but you have to
understand why cuz that's the leverage
you know like i prefer being
underestimated by madison avenue it's
our strength you know teo still to this
day after everything that's out there in
our industry think vaynermedia is mean
with a bunch of interns still to this
day
I love the romance of me thinking on
mommy present and have this incredible
EQ but you can't get high on your own
supply
like I'm thrilled that I have good
intuition and helped me scale fine but I
always think I could be equally as wrong
and you just do the best you can
hey would anyone you don't do the man
thank you my god
how are you sure I'm such a badass post
that pic that pic in general is great
great right and perfect for the quote -
I never say
you the copy's fire the fans aka anyone
who had an opinion about me said to me
that a website wouldn't work that email
wasn't better than direct mail that
Google Ads weren't as good as yellow
pages that YouTube was a fad that
Twitter was stupid that Facebook would
never be more than a college app that an
agency was a bad idea
that social media was ridiculous that
voice isn't going to be big
when you learn how to enjoy being
underestimated
I think that you know ideology and
reality are very very important I
desperately a lot of stuff you reference
than anybody here who knows me deeply I
desperately want to bring the most value
to entrepreneurship in the world because
it put me on I came from the Soviet
Union we had nothing like the game that
got me to where I am today is something
I admire and I respect that I love and I
want to give back tremendously to it and
I leave economics on the table all the
time for that but I still publicly
always say that I want to buy the New
York Jets it's imperative to have
everybody aligned to the reality and I
do think that every organization every
person does have the ability to have
selfish wants and needs and selfless
acts look we're building what we would
I'd like to call a honey Empire write
the word Empire is aggressive like we
want to build a very big organization
it's I love the game of building
businesses but there's the reason it's
called the honey Empire is we think
we're gonna do that through being an HR
driven organization not a CFO driven
organization to me the culture creates
continuity continuity is something I
believe in tremendously because I
believe in speed speed comes from
continuity you now pumped I get when I
get a superstar into my company and she
or he also is a bad person it's a huge
win for me because I get to sit in this
grass like a cobra and she and he thinks
that I'm gonna look the other way
because they're driving revenue because
they don't realize I can drive way more
revenue in one day than they can in
their whole lives and so the perceived
leverage they think they have because it
worked everywhere else is a massive
vulnerability in my company and when I
sense it in an interview I tell them
this this is the most bizarre and be one
thing if I sandbagged it I actually tell
people what I just said to you literally
that visual and clear and they still
don't believe me because they've been
conditioned to believe money over
everything so I get pumped I don't
usually fire them right away I first let
them create context amongst the whole
company that they are both a a winner
and be a jerk and then I fire them and
then everybody gets recalibrated of like
oh [ __ ] right
honey Empire not empire of honey
[Music]